oh this is juicy you notice a lot of ufo
stuff happening lately with the release
of strange navy pilot videos
and loads of classified documents and
images being released by world
governments we might be on the verge of
a ufo renaissance
to add to the growing mountain of
ufo-related material the cia has
declassified a huge number of secret
files related to
unexplained sightings oh i'm gonna need
my tinfoil hat
you can now download all of these
clandestine records from one location
for free
the docs are currently being hosted at
the black vault a privately run database
and website housing declassified papers
and studies the download includes almost
3 000 pages of pdfs focused on
alien spacecraft encounters and strange
cases of unidentified aerial phenomena
or uaps now this data dump comes after a
long struggle with authorities to make
these files available to the general
public black vault founder john
greenwald jr
spent almost 20 years continually filing
suits filing freedom of information
requests also known as foia requests
asking that the cia disclosed its uap
records
i know this will come as a huge shock
but dealing with the cia was
difficult he said it was like pulling
teeth going around and around with them
then finally he received a large box
containing a couple of thousand pages
so john kindly scanned every single page
for us one at a time
and released into the public and one of
the most interesting documents seems to
prove
the physical evidence of a ufo and you
can see this for yourself
it's document c0551
i'll link it below and it's dated april
1976 and
in the title are the actual words ufo
research
according to the document the cia hand
delivered an
object to a researcher who is advising
the government so what was hand
delivered by agents to a scientist well
we don't know yet because the document
is redacted but lots of people are
digging through the archive to try to
piece this together
and now you can too on the blackvault
youtube channel john has a video that's
over an
hour long where he goes into some of the
more interesting documents you
definitely have to watch this video if
you believe the truth is out there
you might be right and that's the story
time is up
like and subscribe for more